Tommy went around telling everybody he's
much older than he says he is and he
also tells everybody he's from New
Orleans
yeah but he's clearly not from New
Orleans you do his voice perfectly well
oh wait wait
so that number on the Billboard hold on
yes this is a whole normal thing come on
wait it's hello hello this timing wise
oh wait a minute you're when Peter see
the bill bro because you put up a
billboard yeah when people see that
billboard the number goes to you yeah
hello hello well this timing-wise all
whoo this why are you from New Zealand
I'm on on the talk show right now Conan
you know this show in New Zealand
you know God big big red hair
[Laughter]
yeah yeah big red how you know crazy guy
Washington
okay well over you in New Zealand but
you're very famous not here you're on
Conan Conan O'Brien okay
yeah formerly Conan Washington yeah we
have a show here it's mostly a sports
chat show but welcome to the program
okay how good Jack [ __ ] disaster artist
alright
Tata wait a minute you get these calls I
don't know drinking buddy news so that's
pretty fascinating you okay so we did
our own billboard based on that and it's
my face and we have a number and it goes
right here and other than I so I just
revealed the whole thing we've gotten
over like 200,000 calls and you talk to
these people yourself as Tommy as Tommy
do they may never find out it's you well
Seth Rogan went online it was like James
will answer this phone so they'll answer
but I do the voice and they're like
James and Tommy and I think it's like
easier for them to just talk to Tommy so
they just go with that
you